To start this division problem, we want to think about what number, times 3a, is
6a squared, well that must be positive 2a. 2a Times 3a is 6a squared, and 2a
times positive 2, is positive 4a. Next we subtract this second expression. When
we do subtraction, we simply change all the signs. We distribute the negative 1.
6a Squared minus 6a squared equals zero, And minus 17a minus 4a, is negative 21
a, then we just bring down our negative 14 to continue long division. Next we
want to think about what number times 3a is equal to negative 21a. The number
must be negative 7, negative 7 times 3a is negative 21a, and negative 7 times
positive 2 is negative 14. When we subtract this expression, we really
distribute the negative 1 which changes both of the signs. Adding our like-terms
together, we get 0. 2a Minus 7 is our answer and we can check it by, multiplying
it by 3a plus 2.